[Musica]
in un mondo perfetto tutti noi saremo
bravi in tutto saremo bravi perché
avremo un business di successo
avremo la vita che vogliamo anzi di più
un mondo perfetto
saremo tutti altri almeno un metro e
ottanta con capelli bellissimi un fisico
stupendo
o forse anche un biglietto la lotteria
vincente in tasca ma in realtà siamo in
un mondo imperfetto
in un mondo in cui non siamo bravi in
tutto siamo in bravi in alcune cose
siamo mediocre in altre in alcune siamo
davvero pessime e magari sono anche cose
molto importanti la verità quale è che
in realtà tu non sei bravo in tutto e
nessuno lo è veramente oggi sono qui per
parlarvi di come i leader riescono a
trasformare i loro punti di debolezza in
punti di forza è un percorso lungo e da
fare un percorso interiore e molto
personale
partiamo dal primo punto riconosci e
accetta i tuoi punti deboli come fai a
conoscere i tuoi punti deboli se tu per
primo sei così impegnato a negarle
debolezza che hai
mi faccio un esempio
e quando ero piccola e solo in pochi lo
sanno ma anche le persone che mi
conoscono spesso al me lo chiedono non
lo sanno
ero la bambina più timida del mondo un
po perché non parlava bene l'italiano un
po perché i bambini erano un po diverso
mi vedevano una persona un po diversa e
di conseguenza ero così timida che
persino quando ero a scuola durante
l'ora della mensa facevo passare tutti i
bambini davanti a me perché ero troppo
timida per dire scusate c'è la fila qui
un giorno niamh è arrivata mi ha visto
mi ha preso mi ha detto
giada tu sei nata con la lingua usala in
quel momento davvero capito sono troppo
timida e un punto di debolezza e da quel
momento in poi ho detto farò di tutto
per lavorarci su in modo tale che un
giorno nessuno sappia che sono così
timida e di conseguenza nessuno iniziato
da obbligarmi ad alzare la mano ogni
volta che sapevo la risposta in classe e
non potete immaginare l'imbarazzo alzavo
la mano e continua a parlare entro le
stesse ok
devo tener l'alzata risponderò a
rispondere a maniera corretta e anche se
mi blocco non importa perché nel
peggiore dei casi cosa succede
avrò sbagliato ma nel nord i casi avrò
vinto questa sfida e da lì in poi ho
continuato ogni occasione ogni
opportunità che c'era la coglievo
immediatamente per poter sfidare e
migliorare questo punto debolezza dal
accettare di essere moderatore speaker
ad eventi di 10 persone 50 100 500 1000
e oggi le persone dopo mi chiedono ma tu
come a parlare così bene davanti al
pubblico come fai non essere imbarazzata
a questa naturale competenza stesso lo
sapessero che prima ros super timida
perciò riconoscere i propri punti di
debolezza e dal di chi si può partire
veramente per fare un lavoro interiore e
per quel momento lì una volta
riconosciuti gli renderemo punti di
forza punto 2
chiedi aiuto a chi ti sta a cuore è
qualcuno che sta a cuore la tua crescita
personale questo è fondamentale
spesso a sappiamo che i genitori la
famiglia sono persone che veramente ci
tengono di più a noi e ci vogliono bene
sono anche quelle che spesso ci vedono
più bravi di quello che siamo veramente
ma altrettanto sono i primi a vedere i
nostri difetti e a volte le ridono
ancora più grandi di quelle che sono
fatevi tarda loro mio padre diceva
spesso già la tua questo difetto quando
non riesce focalizzarti su una cosa
soltanto ma vuoi fare mille cose insieme
ma se fai così non andrai lontano perché
soltanto se ne fa
fai bene non puoi farne mille farle bene
e da lì col tempo ho capito veramente
squali serve solo su quella cosa
guardare dritto e concentrarmi tutta
sapere qual è l'obiettivo che voglio
raggiungere ed è così che attrae tutte
le persone intorno a te che vogliono
andare sullo stesso obiettivo ed essere
veramente un leader
punto 3 sì molto preparato cosa
significa significa che il modo migliore
l'arma miglior di difesa per colmare i
momenti di debolezza che hai per colmare
le lacune è una preparazione eccellente
mi faccio un altro esempio quando ero
piccola c'era nelle interrogazioni orali
geografia di storia e io ogni volta ero
davvero super preoccupata dicevo come
farò adesso esporre quando uno non
parlavano in italiano e due non ho
nessuna casa con cui posso fare posso
ripeta la lezione perciò sapevo che
dovevo studiare il doppio devo ripetere
il triplo e dovevo avere il quadruplo
del coraggio per presentarmi in classe
ed esporre l'interrogazione e in più non
potevo parlarne a casa perché ovviamente
i genitori non parlavano bene italiano e
quindi se avessi provato a ripetere a
lezione sarebbero anche addormentati
perciò mi sono comprato registratore
vocale mi registravo mi riascoltavo e lo
facevo all'infinito fino a quando dicevo
ok ora sono sicura che va bene quindi
siate preparati ma molto preparati e
questo modo migliore per cole per
colmare i boom di debolezza punto 4
assumi le abilità che ti mancano
cosa significa da imprenditore devi
riuscire a capire quali su una vita che
tu hai veramente e quali non hai non
potrai mai avere tutte le abilità e non
potrai mai essere la persona che può
fare tutto e di conseguenza trovare la
persona che può colmare il tuo punto di
debolezza è il modo migliore per
veramente riuscire
a prendere un impresa e portarla
successo e una volta trovata qualcuno
nel team che possa colmare questo punto
debolezza avrei sviluppato ancora
un'altra competenza ed è quella di
riuscire a porre fiducia al 100 per
cento in qualcuno che fa qualcosa di cui
non casa e niente non capisci niente li
togli completamente fuori e soltanto
dare fiducia alle persone che lavorano
per te che riuscirai a potenziare queste
persone e loro vorranno lavorare con te
e perth e ultimo punto diventa un leader
con competenze orizzontali
mi direte ma io ho appena detto che non
potete sapere tutto e fare tutto però
bisogna sapere almeno un minimo su
ciascuna cosa qualche giorno fa ero con
uno di questo imprenditore che un
imprenditore di più successo in tutta
europa nel mondo della tecnologia e lui
mi ha detto sai già da quando ero
piccolo fino anche qualche anno fa e
tecnologie non ne sapevo nulla
però da quando ho creato l'azienda ogni
weekend
studiavo tutto ciò che dovevo imparare
per poter almeno parlare e confrontarmi
con ingegneri per poter confrontarmi con
tutte le persone tecniche perché sono io
come faccio a dare loro una scadenza e
capire se quel compito quel prodotto è
fattibile è un approccio molto
intelligente questo e si può e si può
utilizzare in tutti gli altri settori e
ambiti perciò quello che voglio dirvi io
è che tutti di noi tutti noi abbiamo
delle delle debolezze e se noi oggi
dovessimo mappare le debolezze tutte le
persone in questa platea sono sicura che
sono debolezze su cui possiamo lavorare
facilmente sono debolezze immutabili
spesso ne vediamo però molto più grandi
di quello che dovrebbero essere e quindi
diciamo no non ce la farò mai
no sono troppo timida no non riesco a
parlare avanti al pubblico invece sapete
c'è nelle persone che hanno anche delle
debolezze che sono immutabili
ma nonostante ciò sono riuscite a
renderle punti di forza questa persona
al qui in qualcuno la conosce stephen
hopkins si o no che cosa aveva era
malato di sla
nonostante ciò è diventato una delle
persone più ammirate da tutti i fisici
per le scoperte le pubblicazioni che ha
fatto forse questa persona a cui via
meno familiare lui si chiama chris brown
chris brown invece era affetto di
paralisi celebrale fino ai cinque anni
non riusciva minimamente a parlare da
cinque anni in su
era paralizzato tutto il corpo tranne
che il piede sinistro e ha scritto nella
sua vita
una biografia che si chiama il mio piede
sinistro
questa persona come forse la foto non mi
dice nulla ma se guardate i suoi dipinti
capirete subito chi è parliamo di
vincent van gogh
sapete bene che vinse mangog avrà una
malattia mentale
nonostante ciò è stata una delle persone
che ha influenzato in maniera
incredibile tutto movimento artistico
della soia epoca ma è questo lo
riconoscete è il famoso beethoven a
volte ci pensate della musica che
ascoltiamo dopo tanti tanti anni è
qualcuno che l'ha composta ed era
qualcuno che era assurdo e lui e
beethoven è famoso per le meravigliose
composizioni e improvvisazioni che
faceva con questa cosa voglio dirvi sono
tutte debolezze che loro veramente su
riuscita a portare come come punti di
forza e creare qualcosa su quelle perciò
se trovate veramente il coraggio e con
quel coraggio ne uscirete vincenti e
vittoriosi per questo se l'hanno fatta
loro ce la possiamo fare anche noi
giusto
il percorso per capire quali sono le
cose che ci rendono insicuri è un
percorso molto difficile
un percorso in cui veramente dobbiamo
prendere
nel tempo e riflettere su noi stessi in
un mondo di oggi siamo così impegnati da
mille altre cose che ci dimentichiamo di
fermarci e veramente pensare ma sto
facendo la cosa giusta
sono davvero contento lo sta seguendo
semplicemente la massa quando inizierà è
veramente a conoscere te stesso
solo quando impari rai veramente essere
consapevole di chi sei
scoprirai di avere una forza che non
pensavi neanche di avere prima abbiamo
parlato di incompetenze di qualità di
debolezza di punti di forza se qua sono
talenti che puoi costruire nel tempo o
talenti nati ma questo non serve a
niente se accanto non c'è duro lavoro
non c'è duro lavoro ogni giorno e questo
costante voglia di provarci di farsi
vedere e di non mollare mai
quello che però vorrei dirvi è che in
questo momento più andate avanti più
rendete conto che veramente la variabile
importante quale è il tempo noi siamo
tutti responsabili
abbiamo il potere di controllare nostro
tempo perciò usatelo veramente con
saggezza
quindi se volete veramente portare il
cambiamento della vostra città in quello
che fate nel lavoro che fate
partito da voi stessi e partendo ve
siete perciò concluderò con una frase
molto famosa ma che fa davvero bene
ripeterci
ogni tanto se non qui dove se non ora
quando e se non poi chi grazie
[Applauso]